tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fabi j
oggi siamo tornati su alieni selection
erano rimasti che ovviamente stiamo
impersonando non ho capito bene chi sta
impersonando però come parimenti è stato
trovato al pianeta il pianeta di alien
sono più cazzola curioso perché questa è
veramente il pianeta di alien quindi il
primo incontro ad altro posto superando
la gancia facciamo castro è la molla
motogp e meno adrenalinica e questo ve
lo dico cio fatta cioè voglio essere il
primo a morire in questa spedizione
quindi è inutile che cammini veloce si
guarda queste formazioni rocciose e già
sembra mio pube vabbè io prossimo ma io
sono prassi perché sembrava salgo io
vai vai ai tiramisù fatti forza perché
questo 280 kg era ce la puoi fare
321 sì se non è vero pensavo 5 kg
bagnato però va bene grazie
stai lì e io vado a morire ragazzi
stiamo andando nella merda bellissimo da
soli poi quella è la nuova sala giochi
cannes aperti in centro
ho visto il film di alien secoli fa pro
non mi ricordo più però sta roba c'entra
qualcosa ottima la scelta del design tra
l'altro fatto che è successo perché
trova la fonte le 6 a ci siamo
avvicinati direttamente da questo punto
entra nel relitto entrò nel seme che
cos'è il titanic ti togli che sono io
primo start guardaroba raschiati giorno
la madonna cos'è sto schifo si paga
l'entrata è stata un no guardi andrà
magnetica sono terzo subito ma dalla
ragazza meglio che la mario kart lastra
di proprio
il primo è la lava parco puoi portarmi
la palla adesso che siamo qua dentro
fatemi capire che cosa dobbiamo trovare
di bello o [ __ ] se starò la ragazza è un
cannone una roba tipo king persone
ammetto la mia ignoranza non ho visto
ali di recente quindi non mi ricordo
fino a 6 è sta roba
cos'è che è successo ma manco per il
cazzo no no no non è mai presente tipo
preferisco tagliarmi il pene si buttò
tua nonna qua dentro
vado vado io io per primo e ci
mancherebbe che andate voi andare io
perché sennò non siete contenti stronzi
beh lui me lo ricordo questo e non
ricordo quando ti vedo vicino 8 minuti
fico un buon calcio che non è da prova
permesso
è così lascio mi piace bravo così itagui
almeno dai ragazzi lasciatelo voi mi
piace perché qui non manca gato modello
ascoltami molto allegro come poi
complimenti è veramente che qualcuno
vuole una frittata no perché di uova ce
ne andiamo ragazzi
sì sì fai attenzione lo dici a tua mamma
perfetto allora andiamo giù i ragazzi
siamo messi malissimo perché io non
sarei tanto tranquilla in mezzo a quella
merda
fate quello che volete poi è però vabbè
prega ragazzi perfetto ok non mi ricordo
bene la trama di alien e promi mi pare
che fossero uova al tegamino proprio
fuori capire un attimo ma cos'è che è
successo che ha un filmato proprio che
si succedono ragazzo filmato così non è
perché madonna mi sa che è scaduto ed io
non lo so e non lo mangerei euro fai col
web cosa fai
vuoi controllare dentro è mio dio che
schifo beh decisamente scaduto amico chi
è questa cosa fai
non tocca non toccare chi è brutto e
presente essere [ __ ] nel
cervello ecco proprio quello che
rappresenta via prese che non sono
giochi indietro no al nostro più bello
no è che capito per portare la pina
automatico se vuoi sapere il resto fammi
uscire da qui siccome faccio con
l'uscire è così allora sai dove trovarmi
che è stronzo
devo fà ragazzi che hanno capito parte
c'è qualcosa che potrebbe servire
comunque ragazzina una storia da
raccontare i bambini prima di andare a
dormire perché hai un lancia un
lanciafiamme tra [ __ ] roba per natale
io sono fottutamente a posto pronunciare
qualcosa gira fammi vedere il culo abela
torres eastern ora ga veramente ma
funziona proprio posso sparare alle
persone brutte zio vieni qua mi dico
avvicinati bravo bravo così
fai così bruciano dio mio no per me lo
bruciato davvero cosa ma serio ma cosa
correggere che non fa non sapete stare
manco agli scherzi ma dio mio scorri
ascoltavi scherza dov'è andato io
scherzavo
stavo scherzando non o quello qual è il
muro devi andare no quello è l'altro
muro bravo perfetto c hai azzeccato
non so se messo a correre cielo bruciato
ascoltami se fai così ti brucio anche la
mamma ecco d'accordo ragazzi torniamo
indietro perché non è stato bello
bruciare gente però non è proprio quell
obiettivo del gioco diciamo prove
d'affetto non attaccare gli alleati ai
rom nati questi anche scusa porca [ __ ]
di quella [ __ ] di quella mamma di alien
brutta ma vista proprio brutta
l'individuo attiva il sistema di
spegnimento di incendio [ __ ] sono
morto
che cazzo è successo devo riprendere la
prima se mi chiami sono preso un colpo
allucinante raggiungere il punto di
raccolta ma sto cazzo mi chiami esplosa
la quanto possa mazzoni la famiglia
l'imi anche rompere i [ __ ] to torcia
umana di sto cazzo fai come che cosa
aveva è morto e facce morna nomi e vabbè
che cazzo premere in caso di incendio ma
è così
ho sempre desiderato farla sa cosa nella
mia vita meno male almeno qui appena
esploso qualcosa la giovane mamma a fico
ma che cazzo dici ma era già stato un
petardo più bisogni le cose proprio la
notte è figurati quanto è bello riuscire
a tornare in questi posti fantastico
proprio d'altro ecco di qua di qua
ragazzi devo
tua madre che cazzo ci fai tu qui volta
mi fratello guarda sono contento che tu
non mi abbiamo sbranato il cervello però
di qua c'è un tizio brutto sono troppo
contento che almeno lui e non è un
deficiente prof
cos'è sta roba verde a via l'isolamento
si è perfetto da ragazzi stiamo
praticamente stiamo intrappolandola
alien qua dentro solo che è leggermente
un macello è però non so se ce la faremo
mai pro ci proviamo sono straconvinto
mostra convinto che non riusciremo mai a
fare stack agata prima di chiaia in c
fotta perché tanto non se ne mancano due
ma tu sei quello che ho bruciato prima
scalata inizia su mi dispiace ti
raccomando di lievitazione sì sì sì sì
tranquillo faccio io a via l'isolamento
si è già fatta e rifatta voti ai
perfetto abbiamo fatto zio lo sapevo
elettrica più un attimo ok dove dove
doveva attivare
devo disattivare la roba qua
allora calmi ragazzi è sceso è sceso è
successo quel gente di merda come ha
fatta scendere veramente si vede ovunque
perché lo stiamo intrappolando sta sta
funzionando la cosa al problema è che è
ovunque quello stronzo di qua c'è un
codice lamette fusa mettono no sì ce la
faccio lo faccio
sì ma si può mai a tirare una roba
mentre c'è alien che ti gira per la casa
bellissimo
per questo dover creare cosa devo fare
qui dai maledizione ore per attivare una
merda è perfetto migliaccio messo aree
ma ce l'ho fatta
adesso diritti e bastava fare esegui
come amministratore zio era prima che i
ragazzi da domani io al suo rumore
brutto
no non ci credo non posso uscire più no
non ci credo sono rimasti intrappolati
scappa dal server centrale ma stesso
rimasto intrappolato che cazzo scampo ce
la posso fare se mi nascondo ma mio dio
[Applauso]
no non venire il quando non tanto ha
dato a marzo la famiglia
l'ho fatta ho fatto casa andando che
caccia fa spari sei fumato qualcosa è
sparito bene ragazzi spagnoli importante
che senza è andato a minchia dove devo
andare
serve controlli qua mi chiama veloce
però prima che mi torni a terra che ci
siamo ma c'è chi caccia fatto questo
fucile
non ci saranno non doveva finire così
[ __ ] di merda ma [ __ ] [ __ ] per
questo quando spara alla gente questa
qua è mia amica quando non gli sparo mi
faranno l'ora ma ora siete coglionazzi
ragazzi romani che culo ma girato che
culo non ha girato di qua che botta di
culo dove devo andare io non sto capello
mi ha visto di morire è andato via sì il
fuoco che culo
che botta di culo veloce dovevo andare
dove cazzo vado meno di te non di quelli
qua veloce veloce lasciano certo sì sì
fuorché a fuck yeah
ci ho messo ha reso messo un'ora per far
sta stronza attivare ciao ziaco insight
senti allora scatta fratello che
[ __ ] mi aprì la porta in faccia
qualcosa
graziati
cioè botta di cui solo perché quella
merda mi aveva segnalato nel mio caso
quello quello sarebbe mio ed efficiente
prove ma se ti prima allo vicino per non
ho ascoltato cosa farò ma che fluttua
peraltro vedo attraverso i muri
bellissimo dove si mi carica però non è
così perché non sono tirato dentro sono
un deficiente
sono uscito gli attivare il mio raggio
ok sono andato perfetto ragazzi sono le
cose più belle della vita questa che
vedete c'è io apprezzerei la tua
bellezza ti manderei anche a miss italia
però cribbio mi sa che non ci passi in
cosa fare se innamorato del muro non sta
tornando indietro effetto di scorta zio
ok non mi ha sinceramente non ti seguo è
però grazie di avermi fatto capire che è
che ognuno può essere bello se si sa
ottenere questa roba beenie man e
fluttuante che se poi la uso mi ritorna
in mano certo torch altra cos'è ai
potenziato la torcia al plasma cos'è
fiamma la fantastica usa la facciata che
devo fondere la porta mi mancava sta
cosa lo fai abbastanza veloce perché se
non te ne sei accorto quel tizio ci sta
giusto al culo è un ragazzo è stato
assistenza da per caso su tutta mia cosa
vuoi tu fatti un giro in là ecco bravo
per vedere
poco cotti sembra attesa che non sa dove
sta andando ma ti pare
ascoltami geo tv chi mi hai preso dove e
come effetto questo aspetto umano e
computer a casa oppure permesso solo io
faccio colori gol tipo di situazione ok
allora ascolta che cazzo vuoi devi stare
per calarsi perché mi deve attaccare
ogni volta che faccio se io voglio
toccare il computer lo faccio
hai capito non lo brucio perché poi mi
dispiace prova adattamento devi smettere
di fare il figo perché non sei tu non
sei più tu lo sai di più mi butto là di
tutto c'è un armadietto si ci rimangano
nella roma valido voce e veloce veloce
l'accordo ragazzi concluso qui
l'episodio è stato assurdo comunque nel
prossimo padre della non vi spoiler o
nulla pero il capito chi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come sergio servito è piaciuto
se non commento mi piace anche a pagani
facebook e come nel video trovata nella
descrizione forse dovresti riscrive tele
ci vediamo un prossimo video delle
ragazze